[Music]
recently a Muslim drove up to bluestone
church in west conshohocken Pennsylvania
while the service was going on he wasn't
there however to engage in interfaith
dialogue what he did there was a
menacing glimpse of what is likely to
become a common occurrence at churches
across the country john stange of
bluestone church tells what happened the
front of the church is very close to the
edge of the road and while I spoke this
evening about the sacrificial love of
Jesus and how Jesus calls us to love one
another with that same kind of
sacrificial love I noticed that a man
pulled his car up to the entrance of the
church and he sat there during the
course of the message for over thirty
five minutes at first I assumed he was
waiting to pick someone up from one of
the nearby homes then I wondered if he
was planning to attend to the service
but wasn't sure where to park but soon
it became clear that he wanted to hear
the message from his car so he parked in
the fire lane outside the church and
listened it seemed a little curious to
me but didn't immediately strike me as
alarming stang he continued as I was
wrapping up the message he began yelling
into the building I wasn't sure what he
was saying at first so I stopped
speaking and walked toward him so I
could engage in conversation with him it
quickly became clear that he took great
offense to what I was preaching about
and in the midst of yelling at me he
stated you press on my nerves you press
on Muslims nerves you're going straight
to hell on the day of judgment
apparently he was Muslim and he wanted
to make sure that I knew he had a
problem with the Christian message I was
preaching as our towns and cities grow
more diverse they will be increasingly
enriched by encounters such as this one
celebrate diversity our diversity is our
strength this man only shouted he didn't
pull out a knife or a gun and start
murdering infidels he must be a moderate
but his statements weren't closer
scrutiny how exactly did John stange
press on Muslims nerves
he wasn't preaching about Islam or
Muslims he was simply speaking about his
Christian faith but that was enough to
set the Muslim intruders nerves on edge
and lead him to begin shouting and
fulminating about how everyone there was
going to hell meanwhile this incident is
a lot
today the third anniversary just passed
of the American freedom Defense
Initiative jihad watch Muhammad art
exhibit and cartoon contest that was
attacked by jihadis in Garland Texas in
the wake of the attack not a few
Christians told me that I had done a
terrible thing in Co organizing and
speaking at the event they claimed that
the events primary organizer Pamela
Geller and I were to it asleep provoking
Muslims and brushed aside our response
which was that to bow to intimidation in
that case the threat of violence against
those who drew Muhammad would only
encourage more intimidation very well
but those Christians should take careful
note of this incident in Pennsylvania
they thought that Pamela Geller and I
were poking Muslims in the eye by
holding our event in defense of the
freedom of speech and that we should
have been more respectful but in the
congregation of blue stone church in
west conshohocken Pennsylvania nobody
was provoking Muslims at all and they
still ended up being accused by an
enraged Muslim of pressing on Muslims
nerves the lesson is clear some Muslims
consider any expression of the Christian
faith as well as any expression of other
non-muslim religions as provoking to
Muslims as this Muslim did in
Pennsylvania and as an intolerable
affront so all the good Christians who
castigated us for holding our free
speech event in Garland Texas should be
consistent if their intention is to
avoid provoking Muslims at all costs
they should close down their churches
now and convert to Islam it would be the
tolerant thing to do
I'm Robert Spencer a showman fellow for
the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the Center for
security policy
you